الى ملف اخر تحديدا الى تطورات المشهد في
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا فقد افد مراسل
الجزيره بتجدد القصف الروسي على مقاطعه
خيرسون جنوبيه البلاد كما اكدت السلطات
الاوكرانيه في المقاطعه ان القوه الروسيه
قصفت الاقليم خلال الساعات الماضيه مره
عده
قياده عمليه الجنوب الاوكرانيه ان قصر
مدفعيه المتبادلا يجري عند ضفه نهر
المقاطعه واذا قوات روسيه تعرضت لهزيمه
وصفاتها بالكبيره في منطقه شابين الكا في
خلصون واضافتنا قوات روسيه تواصل سحبه
وحالتها من المناطقها على طول الضفه
الشرقيه للنهار
الاوكراني ايضا استمرار القصر الروسيه على
مقاطع
قطعت بريانس كروسيه المنتخب للحدود مع
اوكرانيا ان القوات الاوكرانيه قصفت بدت
سوزوكي الحدوديه مما تسبب في القطاع
الجزئي لتيار الكهربائي حاكموا بريانسكا
اضعف ان خطوط السكك الحديديه في المنطقه
قد تضررت نتيجه القصف الاوكراني لكن من
دون تسجيل اي اصابه
الان ما معنى من خرسا مراسل الجزيره تامر
عصمادي
ومن موسكو مدير مكتب الجزيره زور شواش
ارحب بكم هذه اخر تطورات المدنيه تحديدا
فيما يتعلقصه
نعم ازدهار التطور الابرز هو في تشابلانكا
كما قالت السلطات الاوكرانيه تحديدا هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه التي قالت خلال الساعه
الاخيره بان هزيمه فادحه تعرضت لها القوات
الروسيه الموجوده هناك وتحدث عن منطقه من
الضفه الاخرى من نهر دنبر في خيرسون حيث
يجري قصف مدفعي من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
باتجاه مواقع تمركز القوات الروسيه قياده
عمليات الجنوب قالت بان هنالك قتلى وجرحى
في صفوف القوات الروسيه المتواجده هناك
وان الارقام سوف تعلن تباعا لكن هيئه
الاركان تحدثت عن هزيمه فادحه كما وصفتها
في تلك المنطقه في المقابل عموم اقليم خير
سون وفقا ل- قياده عمليات الجنوب
للقياده العسكريه الاوكرانيه في خير سون
تتعرض لقصف متواصل بالمدفعيه من قبل همم
الجيش الروسي والحديث عن اكثر من 40 هجوما
مدفعيا خلال الساعات الماضيه عموم
المقاطعه تحديدا مركز المدينه والعديد من
القرى والبلدات الواقعه على خط التماس
موجات النزوح ما زالت متواصله في المدينه
الكثير من السكان ينزحون في هذه الاثناء
وسط انقطاع كامل للكهرباء للماء للخدمات
في المقابل تقول السلطات الاوكرانيه
تحديدا هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه بان هنالك
انسحابات تجري منذ ايام حتى اليوم لبعض
وحدات القوات الروسيه المتواجده على الشرق
النهار شرق نهر دنيبر والتطور اللافت ايضا
في زبرج خلال الساعات الماضيه تحدثت
السلطات الاوكرانيه هناك
القياده الاقليميه العسكريه في جبروتيا
بان شيئا مشابها يجري في ميلاتوبيل التي
تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه في ريف
زباروجا الجنوبي لما جرى في خرسون تقول
بان هنالك ايضا انسحابات من ميليتوبل
انسحابات من تكناك على واقع القصف
الاوكراني المتواصل على تلك المناطق تلك
الاماكن اللي توبل تنظر اليها القوات
الاوكرانيه بحساسيه مفرطه لا سيما انها
تنظر اليها باعتبارها خط امداد للقوات
الروسيه المتواجده في محطه
النوويه وبالتاكيد القصف وفقا للقوات
الاوكرانيه القذف الروسي بطبيعه الحال ما
زال متواصلا على دينيبر وسط جنوبي البلاد
على المناطق الساحليه والمائيه في ميكو
لايف ايضا القريبه همم من هنا وهمم
بالتاكيد الوضع متطور جدا ومتوتر وحده
القتال تزداد بشكل كبير في المناطق
الشرقيه تحديدا عند محور باخبوت محور ارض
يفكا الرئيس الاوكراني كان له خطابا خلال
الساعات الاخيره جدد الحديث عن عن الاوضاع
المتوتره في باخموت لكنه اكد استمرار
القوات الاوكرانيه بصد الهجمات بالروسيه
باتجاه باخمود باتجاه ابديه قال بان
القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت تسيطر على
المدينه رغم القصف الكثيف العنيف التي
الذي تتعرض له بخموت وتحدثت هيئه الاركان
خلال الساعات الاخيره عن اكثر من 50 هجوما
للقوات الروسيه باتجاه عديد القرى الواقعه
في محيط باخمود تحديدا اذا تطورات متلاحقه
في الشرق في الجنوب والجبهات لا تهدا ولا
تتوقفنيه يعني تظهر همم القوات الروسيه
وكانها تتلقى ضربات متتاليه وانها مضطره
همم
انسحاب من الجبهاتنا عده ما هي الروايه
المقابله
بيان وزاره الدفاع فيما ذكره والزميل تامر
ولكن في كل الحروب كل طرف له روايته روسيا
تتحدث عن همم
نوع من تنظيم الجبهه في خرسون وفي زبروجه
وانا الاوضاع هناك مستقره وتحتها سيطره
ولا حديث عن اي انسحابات روسيه من هناك
على العكس تماما روسيا تقول انها فعليا
ضبطت الجبهه وتوجه ضربات بين الحين والاخر
للقوات الروسيه الاوكرانيه المتبركزه على
الضفه الاخرى لنهار تلك المناطق التي سحبت
منها القوات الروسيه بالنسبه
المدينه حساسه لا يمكن لروسيا ان تسعد
منها بهذه السهوله عبد الصمد عبد الصمد
بسيط هذا يعني ان الباب سيصبح مفتوحه على
منطقه شبه جزيره القرم وهذا امر لن تسمح
به روسيا الا ان كان وضعها العسكري معقد
للغايه وهذا لا تظهيره التصريحات على
الاقل الرسميه الروسيه التي تتحدث عن
استخدام لحد الان فقط نصف القوات التي تم
استدعائها للاحتياط في اعتبار في التعبئه
الجزئيه التي اعلنت عنها روسيا مؤخرا نعم
الجبهات مستعره جدا في باباخ مونت روس
يتحدثون عن محاصره المدينه من شمالها ومن
جنبها وانا المعارك تجري الان في احياء
المدينه بالقرب من وسطها هناك تقدم للقوات
الروسيه وهذا ما قاله حاكم مقاطعه دونيس
كالموالي لروسيا دينيس بوشيلين في مدينه
وهي ايضا مدينه استراتيجيه سقوطها يعني
انه فعليا ستضعفك هذه المنطقه الحساسه
المحصنه وهي منطقه مناجم ستطعها امام وضع
صعب همم قد يحسب على المعركه فيها لصالح
روسيا ولكن على صعيده الاوسع من الواضح عن
المعركه انتقلت بين روسيا واوكرانيا الى
الاستهداف البنا التحتيه اول امس كان نذكر
استهداف
لمقاطعه بلغراد همم
باربع صواريخ همم كان هناك قتيل عدد من
اليوم صباحا كان هناك استهداف م م محطه
توليد طاقه محليه همم في منطقه حدوديه
بمقاطعه بريانسك المحاذي ايضا همم
لاوكرانيا ولكن دون سقوط قتله ننتظر طبعا
كما ذكرت الدفاع الذي سيصدر ربما بعد ساعه
وساعتين من الان ليحدد لنا طبيعه المعارك
من وجهه النظر الروسيه خلال ال 24 ساعه
تامر حسني